[Music]
welcome back cage riding is when a
motorcycle rider gets into a metal
sphere and races his bike around in
constant motion it's insane and our next
guest is a third generation cage rider
let's welcome to the show alfredo silva
welcome buddy thanks for having me here
it's great to see you man how do you get
involved in cage writing how does your
family start how do you start in this
well my case a little bit different
because i was born into the business
yeah so my great great great great great
grandfather start the circus arts
and the cage riding because of my
grandfather he was the first one he
bought a cage nobody teach him how to
ride he says i'm going to learn this
stuff myself yeah then he learned it he
passed to my father they passed on to me
and how many how many cyclists we have
going in the cage at one time it really
depends on the size of the cage the
bigger the cage more bikes of course but
this one that we use for agt we wanted
to do very uh dynamic and very extreme
so he's a very small cage
basically meant for three bikes only wow
yes tonight america's got talent extreme
what can we expect on the show tonight
look it's bigger than i thought it would
be
first of all i was very surprised to see
travis pastrana
was one of the jugs and i was like oh my
god big biker guy how can i impress that
guy i was like okay we are out of here
he's gonna buzz us or something like
that
but because i combined the globe of
death the cage riding plus fmx riding
together which is the two most dangerous
motorcycle stunts in the show business
together the result was great how fast
you guys going inside this this ball of
death third gear full throttle is pretty
fast wow yeah the g forcing that is
crazy now uh with america's got talent
extreme what do you guys i mean it's
already filmed you can't say how far you
made but what is the grand prize winner
get from this half million dollars wow
all right and the title of the agt
extreme champion so that's the the main
prize now people are watching right now
they recognize you you live here in las
vegas but you also perform at the lux or
the america's got talent show there but
a little bit different routine there
what do you guys do well i did what i
did on agc the first time in the regular
season i'm a knife thrower as well so
growing up in the circus i developed
different skills and i developed a love
for danger so knife throwing here at the
americas got talent las vegas live which
is our first resident show in vegas so
excited about it we do knife throwing
blindfold x throwing and all the crazy
stuff what do you do on the weekends for
all like your down time like i imagine
knife throwing motorcycles in cages
throwing axes what do you do on your
downtime it's pretty busy uh me and my
fiancee my partner on the deadly game i
like to go eat so we explore the eating
places
we love eating we work out i spend time
with my family i have kids in town as
well so it's a pretty busy schedule i
love it alfredo good luck to you america
has got talent extreme is eight o'clock
tonight on nbc
we'll send it over